a lot of people are trying to make  content they can do the stuff they don't  get the heart right they're doing it to  serve them rather than the audience  they're also doing it from a place of  zero expertise so watch a video of mine  and then they'll just pair it back a  diluted version of what they heard  somebody could take every word that I  say and remake a clone video and the  underlying question will always be why  should I listen to you unless the  speaker has a good answer it will never  go viral if you want to be a business  icon you have to accomplish a pretty  significant amount of business accolades  in order to really be taken seriously  don't go broad you can still be the  absolute best person who talks about dog  training in Austin and if you become  more successful then you can talk about  dog training in general you can expand  outwards as you gain the recognition the  evidence that would support your  expertise in the arena